[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 score
l'émission est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département a c'est parti pour le
sommaire football on prendra la
direction de versailles les versaillais
qui évolue en nationale 3 n'ont pu faire
mieux que match nul 0 à 0 ce week end
entre les ulis mais reste dans le haut
du tableau plus d'informations dans ce
magazine rugby à jean fontaine et yann à
paredes 2 heavy noah ont créé une
association baptisée à natanya ni leurs
objectifs
tenez les valeurs du sport à des enfants
bolivie et nous expliquerons plus
précisément le concept est leur objectif
sur ce plateau dans quelques instants
course à pied le départ des 80 km de
l'eco trail de paris sera organisée une
nouvelle fois depuis les yvelines en
mars prochain
le tracé officiel a été présenté la
semaine dernière depuis le premier étage
de la tour eiffel
reportage à suivre l'actualité sportive
de la semaine c'est maintenant sur tv à
[Musique]
on commence donc par du football ont
joué ce week-end sur les terrains de
national troyes versailles recevait à
les ulis dans son stade mot bord on met
les versaillais n'ont pas réussi à
trouver la faille malgré une nette
domination
le résumé du match à montage de jules
grevy la quatrième match nul de la
saison pour versailles ce samedi 10
novembre les versailles et n'ont pas
réussi à forcer le verrou défensif des
ulis lors de cette 9e journée de
national 3 score final 0 à 0 malgré une
nette domination des joueurs de la cité
royale alors bien maîtrisé le jeu on a
eu beaucoup d'action le problème c'est
qu'on manque d'efficacité c'est ça pour
la noce la maîtrise du jeu on était là
on impose sont bas les actions c'est le
sentiment d'avoir fait le maximum pour
pouvoir forcer la décision en notre
faveur mais mais il nous a manqué un
petit peu ce brin de réussite ce dernier
geste qui nous aurait permis d'ouvrir le
score je pense de gagner ce match s'il
attaque reste perfectible la défense de
versailles rassure l'équipe n'a encaissé
que cinq buts en huit matches disputés
cette saison l'arrivée de charles
itandje cet été n'y est peut-être pas
étrangère le gardien de but de 36 ans a
notamment joué en première division a
lancé à liverpool et en équipe nationale
avec le cameroun charlie tanger
c'est un professionnel un professionnel
à une belle carrière une belle carte de
visite
dès que le prestigieux à
coupe du monde donc c'est ça reste ça
reste quelqu'un dans le monde du
football et c'est vraiment une chance de
l'avoir parmi nous au quotidien ce qu'il
apporte par ses qualités de joueur de
footballeur mais aussi par ses qualités
humaines
donc c'est un exemple à suivre pour tous
nos joueurs et c'est un vrai plus il
faudra un charles est en jeu deux gars
là jusqu'à la fin de la saison pour
atteindre les objectifs du club
terminer dans le top 5 du championnat et
pourquoi pas réaliser un parcours
historique en coupe de france et
versailles et sont reposés ce dimanche
18 novembre à l'ess dragon un club
polynésie au 7e tour de la compétition
vous l'avez entendu dans le reportage
les versaillais recevront ce dimanche à
14 heures l'équipe des dragons au 7e
tour de la coupe de france une équipe
peut-elle cnd présidée par l'ancien
joueur de nantes marama vahirua 38 ans
aujourd'hui qui sera également présent
sur ce rendez-vous les versailles et à
partiront en favori de la rencontre on
n'écoute que l'entraîneur youssef chili
on reçoit à domicile donc 5e 1-1
challenge intéressant de d'essayer de se
qualifier pour les 8e tour les clubs
n'arrivent pas chaque saison donc donc
il faut on va pas va pas jouer ce match
là a par dessus la jambe bien au
contraire on va fermer cette parenthèse
championnat pour rire que la coupe de
france
il fait un très bon match pour ravir nos
supporters et et se qualifier surtout on
continue à parler un football dans le
championnat de première division de
district ont joué ce week-end la 8e
journée du championnat
parmi elles les matches phares le derby
maurepas plaisir à la rencontre a tenu
toutes ses promesses
les mort patients se sont imposés 2 1 à
domicile face au plaisir à sous la pluie
on écoute les règles sur micro de notre
journaliste marylène yapi chinois
pour nous c'est un soulagement gagner
aujourd'hui parce que ça faisait un
moment qu'on n'était pas arrivée
première journée donc après une petite
dizaine fait plaisir de retrouver là du
temps avec un gros match on puisse
aujourd'hui
fierté de l'équipe et puis je suis
content pour l'instant juste raid avoir
perdu 2 1 score très serré
mené 2-0 après on a réussi à marquer le
premier but qui nous permet de se dire
on peut on peut égaliser mais
malheureusement on n'a pas pu
concrétiser nos occasions et voilà
frustré une victoire qui permet aux mort
passe bien de remonter à la 9e place du
classement de son côté plaisir
s'accroche à la 5e place
on continue par du handball dans le
championnat de nationale 2 féminin 6e
journée à montigny le bretonneux a
remporté une précieuse victoire sur le
terrain de plouvorn lésigny montrent
elles l'ont emporté 28 à 25 au
classement les saint quentinois se
prennent la 7e place avec 12 points
engrangés depuis le début de la saison
et ne sont plus qu'à quatre points de la
première place du basket à présent dans
le championnat de nationale 3 trap a
manqué à l'occasion de prendre la
première place du championnat
les trappistes se sont inclinés à
domicile face à saint laurent de la
plaine les ivy noir reste donc deuxième
avec un bilan de 4 victoires et 3
défaites depuis le début de la saison
je vous rappelle que les objectifs de
traps reste la montée en fin de saison
on ouvre maintenant une page rugby nous
recevons sur ce plateau le sky rugby
pour lui parler de sa défaite du
week-end à domicile dans le derby
illinois contre l'entente maisons
laffitte saint germain en laye poissy le
score à 17 à 13 autour de cette table
président du sky rugby guillaume payen
ainsi que le troisième ligne maxime
coudray bonsoir bonsoir
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler
de cette défaite maxime wiba une défaite
frustrante parce que
c'était le premier de poule on perdre
quatre points seulement donc on a un mot
je trouve qu'on a livrée quand même une
belle prestation un gros match après
avoir frustré encore une fois on ça fait
déjà deux matches que ça bascule pas
pour nous à la maison en plus voilà
qu'est ce qui n'a pas fonctionné sur
cette partie à guillaume beaucoup de
choses ont fonctionné jal a déjà donc
c'était un gros challenge toujours parce
que ma maison à 8,5 en un poids 6 et ses
gros de la poule clairement donc ses
premiers de la poule et un petit ange
évidemment tout de suite sans en faire
des caisses mais il ya toujours un petit
enjeu est donc après qu'est-ce qui n'a
pas fonctionné
peut-être que la narration fallait être
plus patient encore et saivet avait
gagné jusqu'à dans la région parce qu'on
a arrêté sur leur ligne d'en-but pendant
3 à 4 d'art minutes et on n'a pas réussi
à marquer et puis à quelques petits
points au pied manqués y'a pas y'a pas y
apparaître tout acheter est loin de là
il faut continuer à bosser et que ça va
le faire c'est un pays comme on dit aux
joueurs comme les joueurs sont parfois
les aussi là deux fois sa bascule pas
notre côté deux fois la maison et on y
retourne pas encore un entraînement on y
retourne encore dimanche à bagneux ça va
basculer
vraiment c'est l'efficacité selon vous
qui fait défaut à oscar rugby sur la
partie d'hier mais peut-être qu'on a
quand même eu des occasions au delà des
coups de pied manqué cinq en deuxième mi
temps face au vent on a été
on a marqué un essai et on a été trois
autres fois en position de marquer sans
marquer et c'est là où ça manque parce
que maisons laffitte à tes deux mois a
manqué l'occasion que nous alors vous
êtes actuellement 7e du championnat
c'est votre place vous pouvez espérer
mieux votre avis maxi non moi je pense
clairement qu'on peut espérer mieux
on a un bon groupe ça fait déjà deux ans
qu'on est mené dans ce championnat là
après la montée
le groupe se resserre petit à petit on
fait de plus en plus connaissance les
uns avec les autres on apprend à jouer
ensemble
donc non je peux clairement espérer
mieux et les objectifs sont mieux que ça
on vous sentait que l'équipe est en
train de progresser de saison en saison
en sachant d'où venez vous étiez en
promotion honneur il ya encore peu oui
après forcément la progression est les
combats les plus à mêmes puisque ben on
a beaucoup progressé sur les premières
années qu'il jouait qu'avec ont appris à
travailler avec eux d'autres joueurs en
soirée au fort mesures dont maxime et
fait partie parce que il est tout jeune
il va nous arriver chez les juniors il
ya deux ans et donc donc c'est bien les
intégrer au fur et à mesure et forcément
la profession maintenant et elle est
plus lente vous l'acceptez aussi mais
pour revenir ce qu utiliser la place l
on regarde vers le haut on va pas vers
le bas aujourd'hui quand on bosse
ensemble de mes joueurs ils en parlent
pas entre de la descente possible
descente
non non non non non maxime non
franchement ça nous est pas encore venu
à l'esprit parce que enfin laon perte de
4 points contre le premier si on gagne
ce week-end on aurait pu être dans les
4e 3e manon a pu être donc c'est hyper
serré c'est vrai ça peut vraiment
changer en un week-end tout peut
basculer gens ce qu'est ce qui fait que
ça fonctionne finalement au sky rugby je
disais il ya encore quelques années vous
étiez en promotion honneur
vous avez peut-être le temps de
reconstruire un club un état d'esprit
c'est ça aussi peut-être qui fait la
force du sky rugby en je pense que oui
c'est une des forces effectivement mais
pas seulement cela mais le fait de
travailler avec les gens du club en fait
est de faire en confiance à des jeunes
qui arrivent de s'appuyer sur ce qu'on a
et pas avoir inventé des choses va
vouloir faire venir les gens de
l'extérieur qui sont pas intéressés par
le club
les personnes qui sont là sont contentes
d'être là sont contentes de se
débrouiller avec nos moyens qu'ils sont
très bien et puis après de mettre la
priorité sur le jeu ça que c'est
lorsqu'on travaille c'est tout ce qui
est sûr le jeu et on n'attend pas des
choses de l'extérieur en boissons
progressent le jeu c'est à dire dans
quels compartiments
le jeune rudy la côte et le pop et
collectives tâche
bon là c'est compliqué à dire un
employeur on n'a pas assez de temps je
pense aujourd'hui mais pourquoi pas les
décevoir les unes mais en tous les cas
sur le discours s'est effectivement
priorité est à l'esprit c'est à dire que
le mec est pas capable de mettre le
collectif en avant il existe pas ce
qu'est le rugby donc pas de veulettes on
bosse et puis pour nous c'est les
valeurs qu'on qu'on véhicule depuis
quelques années que le club véhicule
j'espère auprès auprès des jeunes
notamment et et on est persuadé c'est ça
qui fait que ça marche qui fait que ça
dure surtout une stabilité aussi au sein
du club on sent au niveau du staff au
niveau des joueurs également est ce que
ça joue aussi
oui c'est sûr ce que si un club qui est
pas stable après nous en tant que
joueurs on s'y perd ce qu'on perd des
repères chose comme ça s'il ya trop de
turnovers comme ça pareil on perd par
exemple un coéquipier c'est toujours
c'est jamais facile un cap qui est pas
stable on peut pas je pense qu'on peut
pas bien progressé dans un club qui est
passé à la fin de la saison vous
aimeriez a terminé à quelle place
est ce que vous êtes fixé un objectif
fixé un objectif je crois que j'en avais
parlé est vite fait au début de saison
mais c'est tout ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ce sont les joueurs qui se
sont fixé l'objectif est qu'ils nous
l'ont fils et aussi donc en gros on leur
a dit va fixer les objectifs et puis on
va bosser en fonction de ce que vous
vous demandez quoi ce que si on
l'objectif c'est d'être dernier de poule
n'a pas fait rire les entraînements que
si on veut monter par exemple et nous le
métier fils est simple et comme depuis
le début de la
qu'on est arrivé au club que je ferai
donc avec quelques années maintenant
c'est de faire mieux c'est à dire qu'on
accepte pas de faire mon humeur donc
faut gagner il faut gratter une place au
classement face à ces gratter une place
au classement et donc ses lettres 5e et
6e
si on est cinquième ce sera le 104e ce
sera encore mieux mais après la fête a
donc égalisé faut pas y penser la montée
si elle va bien c'est parce qu'on est
bon sur le terrain et elle vient tout
seul alors vous allez jouer votre
prochain match ce dimanche le 18
novembre contre bagneux à l'extérieur
c'est une équipe compliquée à jouer
ou est-ce que c'est jouable selon maxime
maman pour les avoir vu jouer l'année
dernière en finale de ile-de-france
contre sarcelles je pense que ça va être
un gros morceau du calibre de mls gp je
pense après sur leur début de saison je
ne sont pas les pas fou je crois ils
sont je sais plus quel placement mais il
me semble qu'ils sont pas je sais pas
s'ils sont pas dans les milieux où bas
de classement je sais plus juste devant
vous voilà c'est ça moi par rapport à ce
que j'ai vu l'année dernière
je pense que c'est un gros morceau dans
tous les cas tous les dimanches ça va
être un gros morceau puisque c'est une
poule qui est vraiment hyper serré comme
on le disait mais je pense qu'il ya la
place il ya toujours la place avec un
bon état d'esprit et puis dans la
question un pronostic
est-ce que vous pouvez vous mouiller sur
cette partie contre bagneux contre
banier on va gagner victoire bah c'est
ce qu'on va se déplacer pour ça en tout
les cas mais nous enfin tu nous connais
un peu maintenant on fonctionne comme ça
qu'on s'occupe pas trop de drafter on
s'occupe de bosser d'être au maximum de
ce qu'on peut faire nous
sur les entraînements sur les matchs et
puis au final ça la souris rats souris
sourit pas c'est dommage on est un peu
frustré dimanche soir et lundi matin
mais on est persuadé que ça va le faire
abandonner donc là ça fait deux fois que
ça fait pas ou d'un mois
j'avais 200 croire ça n'existe pas ça
c'est faux merci à tous les deux dépassé
sur ce plateau vous souhaite le meilleur
pour la suite de la saison et surtout
voilà plein de victoires mais quand même
merci de résultats à rugby tout d'abord
dans le championnat de division honneur
versailles et toujours invaincus les
joueurs de la cité royale se sont
imposés 23 à 3 sur le terrain de
clermont au rugby club et réalise donc
un début de saison parfait avec cinq
victoires en cinq matches
au classement les versets compte
maintenant 24 points et s'envole au
classement et compte cinq points
d'avancé surmonter son prochain match
dimanche prochain sur le terrain à de la
nuit en fédérale 2 l'équivalent de la
quatrième division nationale plaisir a
réalisé le gros coup du week end les
pzero ont battu ce dimanche à
l'extérieur chartres sixième du
classement
score final 19 à 17 une performance qui
permet aux yvelinois de remonter à la
10e place du classement avec 13 points
et de s'éloigner un peu de la zone de
relégation
prochain match dimanche prochain à
domicile contre l'équipe du run
nous allons maintenant parler de
l'association à natanya ni qui prône les
valeurs du rugby jean fontaine vous êtes
le président et ian paredes vous êtes le
responsable l'orgue étrangères de
l'association
alors déjà pour commencer pourquoi avoir
choisi de vous lancer dans cette
aventure et bien bonjour bonjour bonsoir
qu'est ce que c'est que dès lé concept
alors le concept c'est que ana ianni
déjà c'est un mot aymara donc ça veut
dire jouer ensemble elles aymara
d'ailleurs c'est une langue et un peuple
de bolivie donc moi je suis bolivien je
viens de bolivie je suis né en fait un
robot qui est un village à 4000 mètres
d'altitude et en fait j'ai été adoptés
par des parents français à l'âge de 5
mois je suis revenu en fait ici j'ai
vécu toute ma vie en france
à 26 ans j'ai décidé de retourner en
bolivie pour la première fois et voilà
deux manières un petit peu tout risquer
quoi pour retrouver aussi un petit peu
mes racines petit à petit c'est ce que
j'ai fait et c'était en 2016 et 2017 du
coup j'ai décidé d'y aller toute une
année pour aller faire un projet
éducatif à visée humanitaire qui
s'appelle 4000 mètres d'altitude et du
rugby à santiago de mode tchèque qui est
d'ailleurs un village juste à côté de la
cheminée mais bon voilà ça c'est c'est
juste une petite vaste une petite
histoire là et dont canada natal jan
innés en fait de ce projet là puisque
j'ai décidé d'aller apporter le rugby là
dans un an dans un endroit en bolivie où
on le connaissait pas et surtout les
enfants mais pouvait pouvait pour la
première fois découvrir un nouveau sport
que je pratique une coup depuis 23 ans
donc avec la passion de le transmettre
des autres transmettre ses valeurs
transmettre bas du partage avec c'est
avec ces gamins quoi et entre temps
voilà d'être aussi d'être tout à fait
dans mon rôle d'éducateur puisque je
suis éducateur dans la vie et c'est mon
métier et concepts je sais quoi du coup
à jouer avec les enfants et 20 me et que
les enfants ont dansé clette même avec
les enfants à faire du rugby a donc le
matin en fait intervenir dans les écoles
à être très présent en fait au niveau
soutien ou leur soutien scolaire mais
surtout soutien sportif l'après midi
puisque le matin ils ont cours et
l'après midi s'est laissée libre donc du
coup nous on intervient on va dire sur
un temps 2 à l'e3 heures à 5 heures ou à
26 ans il ya la troisième mi-temps avec
avec les gamins qui est assez sympa
toujours dans l'esprit rugby c'est à
dire qu'on partage devant et que on
vient on les dons qu'on les aide le
matin pour le pour l'école et l'après
midi ont fait on fait du rugby plus
rudes total rugby et du coup vous yann
quel est votre rôle
alors moi je suis responsable des
langues étrangères donc j'ai en fait
voilà quand il est revenu de cette
aventure en 2017 nous a présenté son
projet et en vidéo là il nous a dit ce
qu'il avait fait et c est là il nous a
dit bon alors on vous propose enfin je
vous propose de faire partie de
l'aventuré si vous le souhaitez alors du
coup voilà c'est une occasion je pense à
pas rater donc j'ai dit oui tout de
suite
et vu que je moi je parle espagnol
couramment voilà il m'a proposé d'être
responsable des langues étrangères
donc en gros voilà ça consiste à pouvoir
traduire
voilà sur les sites internet pour
pouvoir avoir accès aussi aux personnes
en bolivie et qu'ils puissent voir ce
qu'on fait cela consiste aussi à
réaliser des projets tels qu'un projet
voilà qui est en cours qui a été donc
pensé par romain duquenne qui est un
membre de l'association et qui consiste
à établir une correspondance avec les
enfants de ce1 taiwan match ac a donc
l'idée c'est parrainer un enfant là bas
et correspondre avec lui donc voilà ça
c'est par exemple on ça c'est des petits
exemples de lettres qu'ils ont pu et
écrite par les enjeux et les miens comme
ça on la voit dire à l'image voilà et
voilà il aime beaucoup ici les petits
dessins et même voix la folie vient avec
le petit drapeau etc français franck aux
boliviens
donc voilà le but c'est vraiment pouvoir
correspondre et moi dans ce projet là
par exemple je traduis les lettres des
enfants et je traduis aussi les lettres
des membres de l'association qui
envoient leur courrier aux enfants en
fait si je comprends bien le rugby c'est
un prétexte finalement pour parler
d'autre chose
ouais tout à fait on a on s'est servi du
rugby à la base pour pourrait déjà
connaître de connaître les enfants
ensuite entrer en relation en lien avec
les habitants du village ce qu'il faut
savoir que l'on n'a pas l'accord si on
n'a pas l'accord des parents d'ailleurs
en font en général on ne peut pas
travailler que les enfants donc là c'est
ce qu'on a fait et encore plus dans ce
village parce que c'est un village qui a
cinq heures de la capitale donc du coup
on est dans un petit village de 500
habitants
vous avez donc l'espagnol qui est
pratiqué mais pas par tout le monde on a
l'oeil marin donc le fameux aymara donc
à natanya nice ça veut dire que je vous
rends ensemble et pourquoi nathalie
parce qu'on a fait on a joué ensemble
toute l'année on a donc
jouer pratique et de tournoi de rugby
des les enfants de santiago lé de 8 ans
jusqu'à 13 ans donc qu'ils étaient
réunis tous les mercredis après midi et
donc on a invité en fait des enfants du
lycée français à la base jusqu'à
santiago donc qui ont fait le
déplacement en fait et avec ce prétexte
en disant bon ben voila ce sera un
tournoi de rugby mais qu'est ce qui est
autour et va du coup il ya le partage et
l'échangé elle a de nouveau si on
découvre on découvre une nouvelle
culture pour les français du coup en
bolivie et puis après pour les boliviens
des coups qui ont pu aller aux francos
et qui ont découvert les locaux super ça
sert de médias en fait vraiment à
travers le dialogue et sport du coup on
peut travailler voilà l'interculturalité
la découverte de nouvel environnement de
nouvelles personnes
mais aussi la cohésion des équipes voilà
il ya un tas de choses la famille la vie
là-bas voilà il ya un tas de choses
qu'on peut travailler avec ces enfants
là les boliviens ils sont réceptifs ou
pas au rugby montré en fait ça dure ça
fait dix ans que c'est forcément un
sport roi il faut le dire non pas du
tout non c'est le foot c'est pour ça que
quand j'ai amené en fait le rugby là bas
on était à voir il était tout surpris et
m'ont dit c'est quoi ce ballon quoi
c'est une va sortir quoi une poussins de
la balle c'est un neuf
non non c'est vraiment une belle de
rugby c'est pour jouer donc voilà il la
faisait rebondir et puis c'était pas ça
allait pas tout droit c'est aller à
droite à gauche donc ça a surpris au
début et puis finalement ça a été
accepté en faisant des jeux bien sûr
qu'on reprenait du football par exemple
avec la balle de rugby et puis petit à
petit von arx moi j'ai vu que ça leur
plaisait beaucoup donc on est passé d'un
entraînement à tour noire à compétition
donc maintenant on est dans ce rugby la
compétition ils sont dans l'attenté
d'une nouvelle compétition
à chaque retour de membres qui sont
envoyées en bolivie ils attendent avec
impatience de pouvoir continuer à
s'entraîner et surtout faire des
compétitions et le niveau s'élève
d'année en année on va vous espérez là
pour vous dire petite anecdote le
premier match qu'ils ont fait contre la
sélection voilà française ils ont perdu
je crois 9 à 3 ensuite le deuxième match
ils ont c'était cinq mois après y
perdent mais alors là de deux petits
points c'était 5 3 hélas cette année on
y retourner
gagner dans le voilà c'était voilà en
fait on augmente petit à petit et c'est
pour ça que du coup il ya le tournoi
national que j'aimerais organiser
l'année prochaine à la passe avec cette
équipe en qui je crois donc de santiago
et même regrouper l'équipe franco
bolivienne avec santiago pour voilà
faire un match et tendre dans toute la
bolivie et toute l'amérique du sud
le prochain rendez vous pour vous du
coup c'est au mois d'août de l'année
prochaine c'est au mois d'août de
l'année prochaine mais du coup on pas en
fait moi je pars donc peut-être que
peut-être et qian d'ailleurs et avec
d'autres
d'autres collaborateurs de de
l'association que je salue d'ailleurs
romain 1 à valentina ma petite amie avec
adrien jérôme voilà de la famille aussi
et qui partent qu'ils participent à ce
qu'ils pourront partir peut-être en août
2019 pour concret ce fameux 30 dernières
questions très rapidement comment on
fait pour vous soutenir
c'est simple alors vous avez la page
facebook humanitaire en amérique du sud
à natanya ni veau natanya ni humanitaire
en amérique du sud
le site internet ww en attendaient 10
points comme et puis après je compte
instagram aussi 1 à 2
un état n'a ni 99 et vous avez également
le blog un chantier go rugby juan point
simpl sites comme ça fait beaucoup
et juste pour vous dire pour nous suivre
et même venir nous rencontrer ont fait
une fête de l'association le 8 décembre
donc ce sera un samedi soir au
rugby-club de versailles que je salue
que je remercie qui est partenaire du
coup comme hec comme voilà les les rubis
par les clubs de rugby tous les clubs de
rugby du court tous les clubs de rugby
du coin comme plaisir avec qui je vais
m'entraîner ce soir le rendez vous est
pris en tout cas merci à tous les deux
de passer sur ce plateau vous souhaite
bon courage pour la suite et surtout on
continue à suivre avec attention
cette association merci beaucoup en tout
cas nous allons maintenant prendre le
large dans cette émission une mauvaise
nouvelle le skipper louis burton
originaire de rambouillet ne verra pas
la guadeloupe
le sportif a dû abandonner ce mardi 6
novembre sur la route du rhum il a été
victime d'une avarie seulement 10 heures
après le départ de saint-malo alors
qu'il était 4e chez les imoca la raison
une poulie situé dans le puy de folle
s'est arrachée et a fait un trou de 30
cm dans son bateau après avoir tenté de
réparer à roscoff en bretagne il a dû se
résoudre à abandonner
louis burton visé pourtant la victoire
avant la course
de son côté le versailles et éric
bellion continue sa route sur la route
du rhum après avoir attendu en bretagne
le passage d'une tempête le skipper a
repris sa route vers la guadeloupe
aborde un majestueux bateau en bois
nommé a comme un seul homme
il est aujourd'hui au large de la
bretagne avec une vitesse de croisière
de 5 noeuds son objectif terminer la
course avant tout et prendre son temps
comme nous l'expliquent dans cette vidéo
enregistrée en fin de semaine
on écoute sur cette route du rhum avec
les goélettes on va
revisiter la performance j'ai envie de
savoir si je peux être performant et
heureux tout en décélérant en allant
beaucoup moins vite que sur le vendée
globe et axone à touba c'est ce qu'on va
faire je pense que c'est intéressant
pour nous hommes et femmes ou et pour
notre société de repenser justement
notre rapport à la performance de peut
être viser plus l'harmonie que la
vitesse à tout prix avec cette goélette
on va bien sûr respecter cette
merveilleuse pour ce et la route du rhum
on va aller le plus vite possible on va
s'arracher on va on va donner tout ce
qu'on peut et c'est là dessus qu'on va
voir si à la fin on a été heureux et
performant éric bellion est à l'heure
actuelle 10e chez les bateaux hors
catégorie un retour sur la terre ferme
à présent on passe maintenant notre page
agenda
[Musique]
on ouvre notre page agenda par de la
course à pied la 12e édition de l'eco
trail paris sera organisé le 17 mars
prochain au départ de lille de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines
le tracé a été officiellement présenté
ce mardi soir dans depuis un salon de la
tour eiffel au montage du jus la
grenouillère d'étrelles en pleine nature
et des coureurs qui vont au bout
d'eux-mêmes voici le programme de la 12e
édition de l'eco-trail le rendez-vous
proposera le 17 mars des courses de 18
30 45 et 80 km entre l'ouest parisien et
la tour eiffel plus de douze mille
participants sont attendus sur cette
épreuve
c'est devenu le plus gros rendez-vous
trail de début de saison où on peut
accueillir des élites les meilleures
élites de la discipline et c'est aussi
en fonction des différentes et
différents formats de course de 18 aux
80 c'est hyper ouvert ce qui fait que
les gens on en a de plus en plus qui
s'inscrivent de plus en plus tôt donc
nous nous inscrivons dès le mois de
juillet ça veut dire près de neuf mois
avant avant l'événement et on est
complet on est complet au mois de
février
parmi les participants fabien parmentier
à coureur originaire de montigny le
bretonneux le runner a déjà participé à
11 édition de l'eco trail et repartir à
cette année sur le 80 km le départ est à
quelques kilomètres de chez moi
et puis ça permet surtout à ma famille
de me suivre en fait sur sur la totalité
du parcours
donc voilà c'est ma course le cas là moi
quoi avec le temps fabien parmentier
connaît parfaitement les pièges à éviter
sur ce départ à domicile depuis l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
faut se mettre dedans officiellement
faut rentrer dans la course où trouver
le bon rythme faut éviter de pas se
faire d'entorse parce qu'effectivement
on part sur la base de loisirs de saint
quentin et puis on part dans un une
espèce de chant qui est relativement
beau ce n'est pas évident pour les
scheer donc faut faire faut rester
attentif aux trouver le bon rythme pas
se cramer trop vite
une stratégie qui l'aidera peut-être à
réaliser son objectif boucler cet ultra
trail avec un temps compris entre 8h30
et 9h30
on continue cet agenda part du handball
en nationale 3 plaisir recevra à bois
colombes au sport pour le compte de la
7e journée du championnat un match très
important pour les plaisirs while
doivent absolument l'emporter pour
remonter au classement
les yvelinois sont à l'heure actuelle
10e sur 12 équipes engagées si vous
voulez les soutenir la rencontre est
programmée ce dimanche à 16 heures au
gymnase nicholas l'air de plaisir et on
termine par un rendez-vous gymnastique
plus de 700 gymnastes venus des quatre
coins de l'île de france vont
s'affronter ce week-end sur une
compétition régionale organisée au
palais des sports d'el en cours au
rendez vous est organisé par la
fédération française de gymnastique et
le club de grs d'elancourt maurepas si
vous voulez voir la compétition l'entrée
est libre
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi à très belle soirée sur tb
[Musique]